I'd like to talk about the second level
book he was a and the 31 Joe count
Carter just to give you some pointers
that you may or may not know about them
here I've put some tape on the ground
but uh
it's a good idea to Mark the area
so if you can see the
the taping question I'll just turn that
camera down a little bit
so if you make a cross with tape if you
don't have tape um
Place something very flat the problem is
then you've got to step over in your
mind or
start confusing about what you're
supposed to be doing
so so I'm just putting the tape down as
an example and then I'll I will show it
in another film the 31
Carter and the points
they use some
these points
that we talk about
we were not uh
we're not born the martial artists
but after many years of training
hopefully you become one
it's very immature to look down you'll
notice that a lot of high grades even in
here while we're trained you know once
they're finished they've done all this
really
you know fast Aikido and then they go
and look down
and it destroys the whole
budo the whole martial arts side of it
you should be able to train yourself so
that I can see where I am on the spot
even and my vision is all around up down
side to side so I know that I'm
approximately somewhere here
so if I'm going to do the third 31 John
Carter
I can learn to go from side to side
and across the tape okay
so
course of time when you get to number 12
you should put it down and it be on the
spot
so those of you who don't know you
should be able to get to the same spot
on 1 12 18
26 31 so there's five points where you
need to finish you know within a few
centimeters of that spot
I've decided after all these years to
make some allowances and that is is
cytosensory said it's oh senses 31
Carter that cannot be changed we're not
allowed to change it
and he made the 31 anti-carata
to go with it because those Scentsy he
tells us that we have to believe what he
said there's no sense he said to him I
have performed the Carter and made this
and please put an anti-car to it so he
done that
now there's lots of uh we're talking
about the second book it was a test
where you have to do the 13 Joe Carter
and the 31 but in the fourth uh level
you will be doing the
31 Kimi Joe
so that's got many variations people
around the world have done lots of
variations and that's okay as long as
you have in mind uh takamusu and
takamusu can be translated in Japanese
to Buddha the word Buddha right so budo
means Marshall
as well as all the different
terminologies takamusu can be
so as long as it's safe for you as long
as it's safety in a martial way you can
change the anti-carter in all different
directions but don't just change it
because it feels good
because cyta says he didn't make many
changes to the anticada
I'm just giving you four warning for
this he said I can't change it much
until I make sure it's a hundred percent
keeping within the laws of budo
okay
So today we're talking about the 31s and
the 31
count Carter
I've been doing this now for many many
years and I've decided that it's okay
when you're doing it slowly and he
insisted that we count because he said
it was a 31 count Carter
but I've found that it's very disrupting
when you're trying to do it at speed to
count
so I personally suggest and this is my
own suggestion perhaps other teachers
will not agree with me I suggest that
you you don't count when you're doing it
with speed
to me it takes out the
to me it takes out the the power you
know you go edge knee Sun you know your
your mind's busy counting and it's not
busy putting in the pounds so if you're
going to do it slowly then yes I agree
Edge
knee
Sun
shoe
this is for the second book it was a
level at the speed I should want it
Shine because if they're teaching
certification not uh you practicing your
own speed if you're doing your own
Carter
and what my advice is don't try to count
with it
you know because
because at 12 it should be there 12 18
26 31.
I think that way you can put more power
into doing the Carter
and leave the county out just do the
counting when teaching and when doing it
broken down the stages
always have some kind of marker if you
don't have
once you've got in the format of
stepping across the
the cross will say the line and you end
up being accurate
and you always know that you've worked
out
basically your your steps your footwork
then
you don't need to
I mean I never use the cost a little bit
uh you will need to use it until you're
completely happy that every time you're
systematic in what you're doing
that I shall make a film and showing the
pace of the 31 Carter
I should bring out some points that uh
I feel that are important
and I hope they
they will help you wherever you are in
the world to do better in warmer weapons
to go forward and into doing the
and making myself and a sense in such a
Sensei happy to know that we're we're
trying to all polish and become more
precise in the weapons it's not a dance
it's not just something that you just
wave a stick a Joe about having a good
time each one has to be precise they're
aimed for things like the heart area
here
side of the head the center of the head
the knees you know that that that they
have to be at Accurate points
um
number nine
when you strike we used to step
forward
and strike the person on the side of the
head
this was uh
done and then Scentsy
decided that in America it was too
dangerous
and it was funny because the cost of
teeth he said to have them fixed would
be too much so he changed this part and
he made us
go backwards so instead of coming
forward
so they're coming forward striking the
head
and then down to here
we step back we still strike the head
okay there's a weakness there that I see
many people do they they turn and they
don't hit the hands
and it starts dropping off really close
down here so it goes perhaps across the
Torso part
and please watch please watch others do
it you know don't take my word for it
watch others do it and see what you
think but it should be a strike to a
heavy
if I was to break it down slowly because
they're two-way
two
or
one
two stepping back
so we'll show you this in a
in a film while I go through the Carter
first of all Counting
thank you for your time I hope this has
helped
foreign